Cody talks about the gun as a way to
express your political will as an sort
of an alternative way to
vote guns are still important because
politics is still
important see what I'm saying there is
uh not that other people's different
politics are important but the fact that
like Politics as an idea is still
important and guns are a certain
admission of the reality of the
political
the threat of the use of violence that's
power that's political
power if you can download this and use
this your vote means a little bit more
or indeed you have a different kind of
vote what I've probably come to realize
far more is that the threat of Guns is
actually more quote unquote dangerous to
governments than maybe specifically in
the United States than um the actual
having of them because they're they're
everywhere in the US the fact that we
have these like oh like these uh debates
and conversations of like just taking
little Parts off of guns and everything
when there's like hundreds of millions
and lots of people know how to make
these little pieces that they're trying
to you know Outlaw um
so I think definitely what changed over
these last 10 years regarding the
politics of guns was how ineffective
they actually are and how they don't
really reflect a large majority of the
people they're trying
to um govern if you will yeah and I know
that behind the defense distributed
headquarters they've got a little
gravestone that has gun control and
blazed on it so that's their idea is gun
control is dead we killed it in America
you know guns are so tied to American
political culture but of course they
have use
out they have political use outside of
our borders and you had a whole segment
that was devoted to that idea like the
Freedom Fighters we are we thought to
ourselves you know what we're going to
do it we're going to try to take up the
mantle the whole idea of of our work is
to enable the everyday common man around
the world wherever he may be to produce
entire Firearms the shift from symbolic
to
practical
you reach a point in being proun where
you stop caring about the Second
Amendment and you realize that being
armed is a human right every part in the
assembly can be purchased in Europe or
can be ordered from China almost as easy
if not easier than Ikea
[Music]
furniture people are building FTC nights
in Brazil in New Zealand in Australia
everywhere and they're posting pictures
and videos there and people are sharing
their ideas and gun control is
dead a lot of things Cody was doing at
the beginning
were you know performance art in a way
those are my words right they were
symbolic they were um they were to
really RI like get people riled up and
understand that we were entering a new
era of like digital performance if you
will and at that point there was a lot
of other creators Engineers makers that
started putting their Creations online
in a far more visible fashion and even
though it's still a pretty Niche uh
environment it definitely has exploded
with different groups and different kind
of like known figures and YouTube
channels and we'll see how long those
channels stay up hey thanks for watching
that clip from my interview with Jessica
solce about her new documentary on Cody
Wilson death athletic you can watch the
full interview right here
yeah